[Musique]
ouais
il faut être chanceux pour trouver
darcis apte à man dans son oeuvre de
winnipeg le producteur de musique voyage
beaucoup
depuis sa première visite au congo dans
un hôpital où sont soignées des femmes
sauvagement violée je suis témoin ya
pour faire plus mal
non non non mon corps ne pas heurter le
canadien a été bouleversé par la bim qui
sépare les pays riches des pays pauvres
par les horreurs qu'engendre cette
iniquité fondamentale là
d'un s'ils décident d'utiliser sa
musique pour aider ces femmes à guérir
elles apprennent à écrire une chanson
plus à chanter sur une partition
composée par le canadien et ses
partenaires c'est une structure toute
seule on file tranquillement du médecin
elle commence à parler y avait un
monsieur qui était notre voie c'est
celui qui m'avait pris par force
sandra a été violée par une amie de la
famille l'agresseur lui a transmis le
sida et la mise en scène après avoir
perdu le bébé sa récupération physique a
pris plus d'un an
puis elle s'est mise à chanter
allawi
bacquet
coeur et amis
a hong kong ou où la guerre perpétuent
les divisions la musique est aussi un
outil de réconciliation entre le rêve
que j'ai désiré être sas a échoué
j'ai toujours l'espoir qu'il y aura
d'autres élèves que je dois réponse est
non
[Musique]
mais non
non
[Musique]
là rien évident parce que beaucoup de
conflits a pas d'argent mais elle crée
une chose comme mon corps qui tout le
monde mais n'aurait coûté c'est sur la
musique c'est sur le sparta est amazon
ça c'est nouveau définition de pouvoir
moi aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]